let's shift to education I again small
government guy but I am the function of
I've only gone to private schools my
entire life elementary school junior
high high school it's a State University
of New York at Binghamton I was a Poli
Sci major they must have done something
right through that so I do believe that
that is one of the functions of the
government that being said we're
obviously throwing tons of money into
education and it's seemingly at a point
where we're seeing less and less results
because of that get us Adams problem
alright so the first thing is that
studies have shown that 70 to 75% of
kids academic performance is determined
by out-of-school factors
so that's parental time number of words
read to the child when they're young
parental income stress levels in the
house type of neighborhood things that
the teacher cannot really control and
teachers know this you know and so right
now we're going to teachers hey take a
hundred percent responsibility for a
process that you can control 25 percent
oh and the educators are like well we're
gonna do our best so the data shows that
if we want to get serious about
improving our educational systems what
we would do is we'd give the kids a
better chance to learn by putting money
directly into their households that's
what the freedom dividend would do it
would reduce stress levels in the house
it would free up maybe a little bit of
parental time and studies have shown
that this sort of cash actually improves
graduation rates and it even improves
children's personalities if their
households are getting some more stable
cash and there's not as much stress and
turmoil in the house so this might sound
counterintuitive but the first thing you
do to fix education is you actually just
put money into the hands of families and
parents so the kids have a shot at
learning the second thing you do is you
have to pay teachers more because the
data also shows that a good teacher is
worth his or her weight in gold in terms
of educational outcomes and one of the
best ways you can attract and retain
better teachers is by increasing comp
and what do we do about the bad teachers
just to take the other side of that
person so I'm pro charter and I think
it's ridiculous that
we're tenuring teacher is that like the
two-year mark or something and make it
so you can't be paid oh you can't be
disciplined or fired and so one of the
trade-offs for a higher level of
compensation would be what you have to
do is you have to empower principals and
school leaders to be able to build their
own staffs and teams and right now
principals have their hands tied by
Union regs and whatnot so you have to
attack both sides of it it's you out
want to attract and retain good teachers
and pay them more and you want to give
principals the ability to hopefully make
changes as necessary so are you
basically for as much school choice as
possible charter schools whatever
whatever it takes whatever a parent
wants to do yes in fact yes I'm Pro good
school and and this is one thing that I
that blows my mind is that people are
just attacking all charter schools but
that's not a lot of the progressives are
not happy with charter schools they
don't want because they want something
more federally mandated or at least
mandated by the government so they don't
want charter schools to me it's like
choice choice you're a parent if you can
send your kids to a school that you like
and it's not the government school
that's right by your house why the hell
not yeah I mean there are excellent
public schools and terrible public
schools there and they're excellent
charter schools and terrible charter
schools we should just be Pro excellent
school and saying that this entire
category of school is somehow relevant
if you were trying to steal man their
argument I mean what is the argument
against charge was I get it that some of
them aren't going to be good but there
are public guys you just said public
schools that are good have you heard an
argument that really makes sense on this
unfortunately I think the main argument
is a political one where teachers unions
hate charters teachers unions are very
very powerful constituency and so some
politicians have said I'm better served
by getting behind this point of view
here's the thing about education I want
to hit is that so many of the the Dems
are talking about free college free
college free college college is way too
expensive we need to bring the cost down
but only 33% of Americans will attend
college
67% will either not go to college or
they'll attend like two-year Associates
or Community College so we have to do is
we have to dramatically invest in
vocational technical training and
apprenticeship programs right now only
6% of
American high school students are in
technical training in Germany that's 59%
so think of that Gulf and then we have
two distinct mattias trade jobs we have
to get micro of dirty jobs and me as
president in the White House being like
these are great jobs and then we have to
get all these high school kids to say
like look college is not for everyone
right now we're we're trumpeting this
fantasy that college is the end-all
be-all College has gone up in price 250%
which has own set of problems but the
six-year graduation rate from a
four-year college right now is only
fifty nine percent for four hundreds
were starting college are not finishing
within six years because they probably
should not have been there are you ready
to have that blowout fight with Bernie
on the debate stage because when he says
college for everybody free college for
everybody and again it sounds good and I
get why he's saying it and then you say
well actually college isn't for
everybody and we need more trade jobs
and things like that people people are
gonna say oh somehow they're oddly
they're gonna say you're the elitist
like you know you finally ascertain well
but that's what they're gonna say it so
you think only a certain set of people
from a certain way of life deserve to go
to college and other people are just
gonna have to suck it up with their
crappy trade jobs I think that's
actually a more honest answer but just
the way the media framed things I mean
you that's something to me that would
really come to loggerheads if the
debates ever get good and get really
about substance you may see that
exchange on June 26 on the debate stage
because it could be just me next - Rinna
give you a birthday present it looks
like a probably college stuff yeah I
mean I'm not and again it's like the
minimum wage it's like am I for bring
down the cost of college yes and my for
pretending that's gonna be like the
cure-all for like our current economic
ills no because it's not
and again the unemployment rate for
recent college grads is 44 percent that
does not change if I make it free it's
like is it better for them to be on
their employed and not have giant debt
loads yes but like is that going to be
necessarily the path forward for
everyone no right and plus the amount of
money we would have had to put in to do
that for them to then not have the path
to the job yes so the what we have to do
is we have to go to the colleges and say
why the heck did you get so expensive
and the reason they're so expensive is
that the ratio of administrators to
students not faculty non-teaching
administer has gone up 150%
over the last number of years so we have
to try and get the administrator at a
student ratio under control
[Music]